une nouvelle étude fait le lien entre
les bénéfices de l'exercice et le risque
de développer le cancer après l'âge de
65 ans il est maintenant déjà bien
établi que l'exercice est bénéfique pour
la santé cardiovasculaire
mais cette étude démontrent un lien
préventif significatif pour la réduction
du risque de développer le cancer
colorectal et le cancer du poumon chez
les hommes d'âge moyen qui suivent un
entraînement cardio respiratoire le
cancer est une maladie multifactorielle
mais le fait savoir que l'exercice tout
au long de la vie adulte peut réduire
son incidence est une bonne nouvelle
bonsoir michel lensois au service m'en
parler de l'importance donc de
l'exercice de la prévention pour la
santé mais leur vous nous parler de son
impact sur le cancer
oui c'est une étude fort intéressant qui
nous confrontent contre inactivité
malheureusement j'ai choisi cette étude
parce que ce n'est tout ce qu'on appelle
prospectives on a suivi des gens de 1971
à 2009
on est suivi 14 mille hommes entre là je
voulais vidy de 40 et 65 ans est ce
qu'on a découvert c'est que plus ces
gens de ces hommes-là s'entraîne plus
diminue le risque de certains cancers
regardant ça ensemble
alors pour ce qui du célèbre cancer du
poumon donc une diminution du risque de
55% et du cancer colorectal est de 44 %
versus des ondes qui ne s'entraîne pas
du tout là c'est un comparatif passé
intéressant oui maintenant pour les
autres cancers est ce qu on a regardé
aussi
oui on a fait une surprise cette étude
là on en a découvert que plus ces
hommes-là s'entraîne plus ils sont à
risque de développer le cancer de la
prostate et comment est ce que c'est
possible chaîne c'est possible c'est un
billet et je vous l'expliqué
sommairement c'est que si vous êtes un
homme de 50 ans en forme vous risquez
d'aller voir votre médecin plus souvent
qu'un autre et le médecin vous a
certainement fait faire un test de
dépistage sanguin pour l'heure pour le
cancer la prostate
ce qui est arrivé c'est quand on a
décelé beaucoup d'hommes on a créé une
fausse épidémie surdiagnostic
surtraitement la mortalité n'a pas
changé alors l'étude à un peu révélé ça
et là aussi révélé que ça on savait déjà
que plus on fait des exercices plus on
dit
il risque d'avoir un accident cardiaque
et donc le message est assez clair alors
pour les hommes dans la quarantaine qui
risquerait ou qui voudrait diminuer un
peu d'exercice physique
oui mais bon c'est certain que ça peut
sembler 25 ans un long bail mais faire
du tennis nagé faire du vélo tout ça si
on le fait quotidiennement pu nous aider
et je pense que dans la perspective où
toutes ces maladies de sociétés là sont
actuellement regardé par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé à la loupe
je vous parle des maladies cardiaques
pulmonaires le diabète et cancer tout ça
est relié à notre style de vie alors je
crois qu'il constitue une bonne nouvelle
d'apprendre ça n'empêche que le cancer
évidemment c'est à d'autres facteurs qui
peuvent être responsables
absolument faut jamais oublier le cancer
l'hérédité le style de vie et d'un
cancer du poumon le tabac merci beaucoup
merci céline